Now I want to talk to you about two parts of what you just said.
One being the possibility that one day we can upload our mind or make copies of
our mind.
You're,
you're up for it
here.
My Little Joe Rogan them from my phone.
You can just call me dude like you the organic version.
But the,
do you think that that's a real possibilities inside of our lifetime that we can
map out the human mind to the point where we can essentially recreate it.
But if you do recreate it without all the biological words and the human reward
systems that are built in the,
what the fuck are we,
I mean,
well that's a different question,
right?
I mean,
I think,
what is your mind?
Well,
I,
I think that there's two things that are needed for,
let's say,
let's say human body uploading to simplify things,
body uploading.
There are two things that are needed.
One thing is a better computing infrastructure than we have.
No.
Okay.
To host the uploaded body and,
and the other thing is a better scanning technology because right now we don't
have a way to scan the molecular structure of your body without like freezing
you,
slicing you and scanning you,
which you probably don't want done at this point in time.
Right?
So assuming both those are solved and you could then recreate in some computer
simulation,
you know,
a,
an accurate simulacrum of,
of,
of what you are,
right,
where I'm getting this,
where I'm getting at an accurate simulate crumb is gay.
That's getting weird because the biological variability of human beings,
we vary day to day
very dependent upon it and we're swimming leg room would also vary day to day.
So with Dva,
Graham and,
and to have flaws because while we vary dependent upon how much sleep we get,
whether or not we're feeling sick,
whether we're alone.
So it is all these,
if you're upload,
we're an accurate copy of then the simulation hosting your upload would need to
have an accurate simulation of the laws of bio physics and chemistry that allow
your body to,
you know,
evolve from one second to the neck.
My concern is you upload would change second by second,
just like just like you do and then we'll diverge from you.
Right.
So I mean,
after an hour it'll be a little different.
After a year it might have gone in,
in a quite different direction for you.
Oh,
some Super God monk living on the top of a mountain somewhere in a year.
If he keeps giving the problem
whenever.
It depends on what virtual world it's living in.
True.
I mean,
if it's living in the,
in the virtual world,
well,
there'll be a virtual world.
If you're not talking about the potential of downloading this again in sort of
a,
into a biologic,
there's a lot of possibilities,
right?
Yeah.
I mean you,
you,
you could,
you could upload into a Joe Rogan living in the virtual world and then just
create your own fantasy universe.
Or you or you could three d print and alternate synthetic body,
right?
I mean once you,
once you have the ability to manipulate molecules at at will,
the,
the scope of possibilities becomes much greater now than we're used to thinking.
My question is,
do,
do we replicate flaws?
Do we replicate depression?
Of course.
But we got,
we do that when we want to cure depression.
So if we don't cure depression when we start,
here's the interesting thing.
Okay.
Once,
once we have you in a digital form,
right?
Then it's very programmable.
So then they stopped the dopamine and Serotonin,
then you can change what you want and then you have a whole different set of
issues.
Right?
Yeah.
Cause once you've changed,
I mean,
suppose you make a fork of yourself and then you manipulate it in a certain way
and you're,
then after a few hours you're like,
well I don't,
I don't much like this,
uh,
new Joe here.
Maybe we should roll back that change.
But the new Joe was like,
well,
I like myself very well.
Thank you.
All right.
So then there there's a lot of issues that that will come up once we can write,
modify,
and reprogram ourselves.
The ramifications of these decisions are almost insurmountable,
like once once the ball gets rolling,
well,
the ramifications of the,
the ramifications of these decisions are going to be very interesting to
explore.
Yes,
you're super positive,
Ben.
Super positive,
but you're optimistic.
Many bad things will happen.
Many good things will happen.
That's a very,
that's a very easy prediction to make.
Okay,
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
I've just a wondering they think,
think about like world travel,
right?
Let go.
Like hundreds of years ago,
most people didn't travel more than a very short distance from their home and
you could say,
well,
okay,
what if,
what if people could travel all over the world,
right?
Like what horrible things could happen?
They would lose their culture.
Like they might go marry someone from,
from a random tribe,
you can get killed and in the Arctic region or something,
a lot of bad things can happen when you travel far from your home.
A lot of good things can happen.
And the ultimately the ramifications were not foreseen by people 500 years ago.
Yeah.
I mean,
we're going into a lot of new domains.
We can't see the details of the pluses and minuses that are going to unfold.
Uh,
W it would behoove us to simply become comfortable with radical uncertainty
because otherwise we're going to confront it anyway and we're just going to be
nervous.
So it's just inevitable.
It's almost inevitable.
I mean,
uh,
of course.
Sorry.
Any natural,
I mean,
yeah,
of course Trump could start a nuclear war and then we're reselling to ground
zero where we get hit by an asteroid,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
so barring a catastrophic outcome,
I believe a technological singularity is essentially inevitable.
There's a radical uncertainty attached to this.
On the other hand,
you know,
in as much as we humans can know anything,
it would seem common sensically there's the ability to buy us this in a positive
rather than the negative direction.
We should be spending more of our attention on doing that rather than,
for instance,
advertising spying in making chocolate and your chocolates.
And all the other things that,
I mean it's prevalent,
it's everywhere,
but I mean how many people are actually at the helm of that as opposed to how
many people are working on various aspects of technology all across the planet?
It's a small group and in comparison,
working on explicitly bringing about the singularity is a small group.
On the other hand,
supporting technologies is a very large group.
So think about like Gpu is,
where did they come from?
Accelerating gaming,
right?
Lo and behold,
they're amazingly useful for training neural net models,
which is the one among many important types of Ai,
right?
So a large amount of the planet's resources are now getting spent on
technologies that are indirectly supporting these singular attarian technology.
So as another example,
like microarray or is it let you measure the expression level of genes,
how,
how much each gene is doing in your body at each point in time.
These were originally developed,
you know,
as an outgrowth of,
of printing technology.
Then instead of squirting ink after metrics figured out,
you could squirt DNA.
Right?
So,
I mean,
the amount of technology specifically oriented toward the singularity doesn't
have to be large because the overall,
you know,
spectrum of supporting technologies can be subverted in that direction.
Do you,
do you have any concerns at all about a virtual world?
I mean,
we may be in one right now.
That's true,
but as far as I know,
my problem is I want to find that program are and get them to make more,
more,
more attractive people.
You know,
that I thought I would say that that's part of the reason why it attracted
people are so interesting I that they're unique and rare.
Yeah.
All right.
Our problems with calling everything beautiful.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
I was like,
well,
you just have to get realistic.
If I get in the right frame of mind that can find anything beautiful and you
could find it unique and interesting.
Oh,
I can find anything below I guess.
But in terms of like,
yeah,
I guess it's subjective,
right?
Really it is.
We're talking about beauty,
right?
Huh?
Yeah.
Now,
but VR existential angst just on the,
when people sit and think about the pointlessness of our own existence,
like we are these finite beings that are clinging to a balls.
It spins a thousand miles an hour hurling through infinity and what's the point?
I think there's a lot of that that goes around already.
We've,
we create an artificial environment that we can literally somehow another
download a version of us and it exists and this block chain created or or
powered weird fucking simulation world.
What would be,
I mean what would it be?
The point of that I really believe,
which
is a bit personal and maybe different than many of my colleagues.
What I really believe is that these advancing technologies are going to lead us
to unlock many different states of consciousness and experience.
Then then most people are,
are,
are currently aware of are,
I mean you,
you,
you say we're,
we're just an insignificant species on the,
on a,
you know,
a speck of rock hurling.
In the other space there's people that have existential angst because they
wonder about what the purpose was.
I ended that I tend to feel like we understand almost nothing about who and what
we are and our knowledge about the universe's far small,
extremely minuscule.
I mean if anything I look at things from more of a a Buddhist or
phenomenological way,
like there's sense perceptions and then out of those sense perceptions,
models arise and accumulate including a model of the self and the model of the
body and the model of the physical world out there.
And by the time you get to planets and stars and blockchains,
you're building like hypothetical models on top of hypothetical models.
And then,
you know,
we're,
we're by building intelligent machines and mindup loading machines and virtual
realities,
we're going to radically transform,
you know,
our whole state of consciousness or understanding of what mind and matter are.
Our experience of our own selves or even whether it's self exists.
And I think ultimately the state of consciousness of a human being like a
hundred years from now after a technological singularity is going to bear very
little resemblance to the states of consciousness we have now.
We're just going to,
we're going to see a much wider universe in any of us.
Now.
Imagine,
imagine to exist now.
This is my own personal view of things.
The,
you don't have to agree with that to think the technological singularity will be
valuable,
but that is how I look.
Know like Ray Kurzweil and I agree there's going to be a technological
singularity within decades at most.
And Ray and I agree that,
you know,
if we buy US technology development appropriately,
we can very likely,
you know,
guide this to be a world of abundance and benefit for humans as well as ais.
But Ray is a bit more of a down to Earth empiricist then than I am lucky.
He thinks we understand more about the universe right now.
I've been that than I do.
So I mean there's a wide spectrum of views that are,
are rational and sensible,
the hub.
But my own view is we understand really,
really little of what we are and what,
what this world is.
And this is part of my own personal quest for wanting to upgrade my brain and
wanting to create artificial intelligence is I've always been driven above our
last borrowing,
the understand everything I can about the world.
So I mean I've studied every kind of science and engineering and social science
and read every kind of literature.
But in the end of the scope of human understanding is clearly very small,
although at least we're smart enough to understand how little we understand,
which I think might,
my dog doesn't understand how the understands,
right?
So,
and even like my 10 month old son,
he understands a little,
he understands,
which is interesting,
right?
Because he's,
because he's,
because he's also a human,
right?
So I think,
I mean,
everything we think and believe now is going to seem absolutely absurd to us
after there's a singular idea.
We're just going to look back and laugh in a warm hearted way and all the
incredibly silly things we were thinking and doing back when we were trapped in
our,
in our,
you know,
our,
our primitive biological brains and bodies.
A stunning the ta in your opinion or your assessment is somewhere less than a
thought a hundred years away from now.
Yeah.
It requires exponential thinking.
Right?
Because if you,
that's hard to wrap your head around.
Right?
It's immediate for me to wrap my head around,
but for a lot of people that you explain it to,
I'm sure that that's a little bit of a roadblock.
It is.
It took me sometime to get my parents dropped their heads around it because they
didn't,
they're not,
they're not technologists.
I mean,
I find if you get people to pay attention and sort of lead them through all the
supporting evidence,
most people can comprehend these ideas reasonably well to computers for 19 six
it's just hard to grind.
It's hard to grab people's attention.
Then mobile phones,
it made a big difference.
Like I spent a lot of time in Africa and all this Ababa in Ethiopia where we
have a large AI development office and you know the fact that mobile phones and
then smart phones and rolled out so quickly even in rural Africa and that if
it's such a transformative impact,
I mean this is a metaphor that lets people understand the speed with what's
exponential change can happen.
When you talk about yourself and you talk about consciousness and how you
interface with the world,
how do you see this?
I mean when you,
when you say that we might be living in a simulation,
do you actually entertain that?
Oh yeah you do.
I mean I think the word simulation is probably wrong but yet the idea of an
empirical,
you know materialist physical world is almost certainly wrong also.
So I'm in so,
well again if you go back to a phenomenal view,
I mean you could look at the mind is primary and you know your mind is building
the world as as a model,
as a simple explanation of it,
of its perceptions.
On the other hand then what is the mind?
The self is also a model that get,
that gets built out of its perceptions,
but then if I accept the new mind has some fundamental existence also based on
the sort of are you feeling the ear like a mind,
there are minds are working together to build each other and to build this world
and there's a,
there's,
there's a whole different way of,
of thinking about reality in terms of first and second person experience rather
than these empiricist views like this is a computer simulation or something.
Right,
but you still greeted as a physical reality that we exist in or do you not,
what does that word mean?
That's a weird word,
right?
It is women who are looking as if reality.
If you look in,
in modern physics,
even in quantum mechanics,
there's something called the relational interpretation of quantum mechanics,
which says that there's no sense in thinking about an observed entity,
you should only think about an observed come observe her pair.
Like there's no sense to think about some thing except from the perspective of,
of some observer.
So that's,
that's even true within our best current theory of modern physics as,
as induced from empirical,
empirical observations.
But in a pragmatic sense,
you know,
if you take a plane and fly to China,
you actually land in China,
I guess you'd guess.
Don't you live there?
I live in Hong Kong.
Yeah,
well cost.
I mean I,
I have an unusual state of consciousness I'm in.
I'm,
that's what I'm trying to get at.
Oh,
if you,
if you think about it like how do you know that you're not a brain floating in a
vat somewhere,
which is being fed illusions by certain evil scientist and two seconds from now
he's going to pull this simulated world disappears and you realize you're just a
brain in a Vat.
Again,
you don't know that.
You write on your own personal experiences of falling in love with a woman and
moving to another,
but these may all be put into my parent by the evil scientist.
How do we know?
But they're,
they're very consistent.
Are they not the,
the possibly illusory and implanted memories are very consistent,
I guess.
I guess my own state of mind is,
I'm always sort of acutely aware that this simulation might all disappear at
any,
at any one moment.
I'm so acutely aware of this consciously on everyday basis.
Pretty much.
Really?
Yeah.
Why is that?
That doesn't seem to make sense.
I mean it's,
it's pretty,
it's pretty rock solid.
It's here every day.
I mean,
so,
so you're a possibly imploded memories lead you to believe?
Yes.
Possibly.
Implanted memories need to believe that this life is incredibly consistent.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
This is incredibly consistent.
This is you UMES problem of,
of induction,
right?
From philosophy class and it's not,
that's not solved.
And with you in a conceptual sense,
I get,
I just feel this philosophy,
you,
but you,
you embody it,
right?
This is something you carry with you all the time.
Yeah.
On the other hand,
I'm in,
I'm still carrying out many actions with longterm planning in mind.
I've been,
I've been working on designing AI for 30 years and my beat designing it inside
of him,
I might be,
and I'm working on building the same AI system,
you know,
since we started open cog in 2008 but that's using code from 2001 the,
I was building with my colleagues even even earlier.
So,
I mean,
I think
longterm planning is very natural to me,
but,
but nevertheless,
I don't,
I don't wanna make any assumptions about what sort of,
what sort of simulation or a reality that we're living in.
And I think everyone's going to hit a lot of surprises.
One once the simulant singularity,
cause you know,
we,
we may find out that this hat is a messenger from after the singularity.
So it traveled back through time to implant into my brain,
the idea of how to create AI and thus this bring it into existence.